Short story
collection,
so it was,
I did it over a number of years,
starting sometime in graduate school
when I was 23 and started publishing
things up through my twenties
and so it was,
I had been working on a novel and I
couldn't crack the novel form at all and
I just kept doing short stories in the
background.
And finally I realized I had 11 of them
that I was proud of and that I,
that could be a collection I hadn't
meant to do the pattern of publishing
short stories and then a novel.
I thought I'm a novelist,
I know it,
but you have to kind of write a lot of
bad novels before you can write a good
one.
I think.
So I did that and,
but meanwhile I love it.
Short stories.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
It was,
they had a contest where,
um,
they would,
for some reason someone in the past love
music,
musical theater.
And so they would,
if,
if you wrote a musical,
they would fully fund it and put it on
the main stage with full costumes and
the set and everything.
And uh,
my roommate,
she said,
we should totally do that.
That would be awesome.
She's the same one who talked me into
competing to be a commencement speaker,
which we did together.
She always had ideas.
She thought no one else was going to try
for this stuff.
So actually one of them we wrote the
night before and submitted it and we
won.
So two years
that prize,
I've tried that and it felt really
different.
Felt like you were
all the stuff.
I think I'm good at like a description
and internal experience and memory.
You can't do that.
Or at least I couldn't figure out a way
was action in present time and it was so
literal,
uh,
I felt really sort of bound as a
storyteller.
I think it would have.
It's a good thing for me to learn how to
do.
I think I learned from it about visual
storytelling,
but place you can do that a lot more
because they're a little more
the audience.
Imagine
the way they do in literature.
There was a variety of task.
Wire was a fiction piece.
It was crazy.
I was a.
That was the first thing I ever
published.
I sent it in.
I was sending in dozens of stories all
over the place against the rule.
You're supposed to double submit.
I just thought I'll send them
everywhere.
I must say I had 200 rejection letters
and then I got a call from esquire for
some reason.
Everyone at esquire had quit the fiction
department over some scandal and the
assistant was left in charge and he,
uh,
published my story,
you know,
it was just luck.
It was a cold pile.